ساعتنا الثانيه اليوم عنوانها الجمال وليس
اي جمال انه جمال علمي مدروس تاريخي
قدم لنا في قائمه عالميه لاوسم رجال
العالم
الممثل الذي اشتهر بمسلسل نتفليكس
صنف الرجل كاكثر وسامه في العالم بعد ان
خضع لتحليل وبحث علمي قيم الدراسه اظهرت
ان وجه وجهه مثالي بنسبه 93% وفقا بالنسبه
الذهبيه اليونانيه للجمال والتي تقيس
الكمال الجسدي هو جميل فعلا استخدمت
الدراسه بقياده الجراح التجميلي جوليان دي
سيلفا تقنيات رسم الخرائط المحسوبه
الحديثه واساليب عاليه التقنيه تسمح بحل
بعض الالغاز التي تجعل الشخص جميلا جسديا
وبالنسبه للجراح في المقام الاول بسبب وجه
الوسيم وعيناه بنيتان الجميلتان
والوضعيه المتباعده
قدمت نفس الدراسه التي نشرت في صحيفه
ميترول بريطانيه الممثل كريس هيمسورث و
مايكل بيجوردن والمغني هاري ستايلز
باللقائمه اكثر الرجال والسلام
عليكم
والجمال في لوحات وتماثيل عصر النهضه في
اوروبا ومنها لوحه الموناليزا وتستخدم
النسبه الذهبيه حديثا لقياس ماده مثاليه
الوجه وكانت اخر من اعتبرت اجمل الوجوه
حسب نسبه الذهبيه عارضه الازياء بالحديد
فحسب النسبه الذهبيه يتم قياس طول وعرض
للوجه ثم يقسم الطول على العرض ويجب ان
تكون نتيجه بحدود واحد فصل سته ليعتبر
جميلا الهجره اخذ قياسات اقسام الوجه من
خط الشعر الى منطقه العينين ومنطقه
العينين الى اسفل الانف ومن اسفل الانف
الى اسفل الدقن وكل ما كانت القياسات
متقاربه كان الوجه اقرب الى المثاليه ويجب
ان يكون طول الاذن مستويا لطول الانف وان
يكون مدى العين افقيا ومساويا للمسافتي
بين العينين وتتم عمليه قياسها بعد من
خلال تقنيات رسم الخرائط المحسوبه الصوره
المثاليه تتكون عبر مجموعه مقاييس كشفاها
الممتلئه والانف اليوناني المستقيم وعظمتي
الخدود البارزتين
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
شو رايك يعني بمعايير الجمال تقريبا
[موسيقى]
يعني كشكل احلى ممثل عربي معتصم النهار
بصراحه
كشكليه يعني وتمثيل برضو تمثيل وحلو كثير
يعني كشكل ووسيم وبحسه انه جدا شخصيته
حلوه وائل شرف صراحه
تمثيله بصراحه كتير مبدع بارع بحب تمثيله
هناك اعتقادي ورائي انه اعتقد الممثل
المصري احمد عز يعني
من سوريا
فاعتقد في بالنسبه لي سامر المصري يعني
معتصم نهار يعني هو انا بشوف انه احلى
واحد في الممثل عربي حاليا يعني وجهه نظري
وائل شرف ممثل اسمه محمد اوسو السيد نور
الشريف كل الاحترام لنا
انا شايف ان ممكن لو فنان مصري
كريم عبد العزيز
ولو فنان مش مصري ممكن اقول الفنان جمال
سليمان انا بنقدر اشوف ان اوسم فنان عربي
عندي ناصر القصبي طبعا انا شايف اوسم فنان
عربي هو عبد حسين عبد الرضا اوسم فنان
عربي وائل جسار انا شايفه اوسم فنان عربي
ممكن بس الخياط مع انه توكسيك بس وسيم
اوسم فنان عربي من وجهه نظري محمود ياسين
في السينما عربي اقدر اقول لك عليه كريم
عبد العزيز كريم عبد العزيز شاب ناجح
ادواره حلوه
[موسيقى]
او لاعب فوتبول لاعب فوتبول
نيمار
دكتور يسعد صباحك اهلا بك معنا شكرا على
تواجدك معانا يا دكتور وما هي المعايير
العلميه الطبيه التي تحدد وسامه او جمال
الرجل
هو طبعا في فرق ما بين الجمال والوسامه
لفظ كلمه جمال ينطبق على المراه اكثر من
الرجل يعني بالنسبه للرجل هو وسامه الرجل
هي الاهم هذا الموضوع يعني بدنا نحل لغويه
عشان نكون صحيحين
من الناحيه العلميه
النظريات هذه في الاساس النظريه الذهبيه
هذه في الاساس كانت
معماريه يطبقوها على كل حاجه في الحياه
يعني كانت طبقت على مثلا على الاهرامات
لكن همم
علماء الرياضيات على الاشياء الطبيعيه حتى
بالنسبه لتكوين جسم الانسان لكن هل هذا
صحيح ولا لا هل هذا ممكن بصراحه يعني ما
اظنه همم همم علميا ينطبخ كده لانه هذه
النظريه لا تراعي مثلا البشره تجاعيدها
البشره لونها البشره نسبه همم البذور
والمسامات فيه هذه الدكتور جمال لماذا لا
نرى عربا ضمن تصنيف الجمال حول العالم ما
الذي ينقص الرجال العرب لكي يصنفوا
بالاكثر وسامه
عربي
ينقصنا اعلام عربي ينشر الثقافه هذه
ينقصنا علماء عرب يطبقوا بعض النظريات على
هذا المجال العرب الموهوبين والعرب اللي
عندهم امكانيات موجودين وبكسره لكن اللي
ينقصنا تركيزه الاعلام عليهم هذه النظريات
همم الاشخاص اللي بيعلنوا عنها اشخاص
بيحاولوا يستقطبوا الاعلام لهم اكثر من
انهم ينشروا حاجه علميه واضح لان احنا
موجود هنا الاشخاص لكن ينقصنا تركيز
الاعلام
ده هناك اقبال من الرجال اجراء اجراء حتى
تجميل يصبح اكثر وسامه
الاقبال الاقبال في السابق كلنا بنشوف
تقريبا
95% من المرضى او المراجعين في عيادات
التجميل يكونوا من النساء الان اصبحوا
اكثر من كده بكثير يعني الان يمكن ااا 8%
نساء 20 % رجال والرجال بيهتموا اكثر شيء
ومنطقه المكشوفه في الجسم يعني همم بعضهم
الصغار في السنه بيهتموا بالجسم من ناحيه
السكس معك ومن ناحيه
طيب الدكتور جمال
الدكتور جمال المراه الجميله يعني ملامح
متناسقه عيون واسعه انف صغير هذا هو
التعريف العام للمراه الجميله بشكل عام
لكن عندما نتحدث عن جمال الرجل او الرجل
الوسيم هل هو يقتصر على الملامح مثل
المراه والجاذبيه اكثر منها جمال
هو عباره عن التناسق بين الاعضاء في الجسم
والتناسب ما بين الشكل والروح يعني هذه
اسامه الرجل لكن الان المراه وبعض البنات
حتى الصغار في السن ينظر الى انه جاذبيه
الرجل في همم رصيد البنك
للاسف الجاذبيه الجاذبيه والجمال
في الروح والوجه لكن لازم نراعي انه
الجمال يختلف الجمال انت ذكرت الجمالا
الاغريقي والامل المستقيم الان في
المستقيم هو الانف العربي لكن الفرق ما
بين الاوروبيين الافريقيه لانه المنطقه
الي ما بين الحاجبين مرتفع
النظريه الذهبيه هذه يمكن تنطبق على
الاشخاص اللي في اوروبا
لكنها ما تنطبق على افريقيا
النظريه هذه النظريه الذهبيه لا يمكن انها
تطبق على افريقيا ولا يمكن ان يطبق على
الفريق
فالجمال يختلف على حسب العرق وعلى حسب
الجغرافيا للناس متواجدين فيها ونظراتهم
الجمال لان النظريه الذهبيه اوسم رجل في
العالم كلمه ما هي صحيحه لكن نظريه
الذهبيه لما تيجي تطبقيها على
مسابقات ملكات الجمال في العالم ما تنطبق
عليهم النظريه الذهبيه
بس خلينا هيك احنا نسالك يعني ناخذ رايك
بحكم انه انت مستشار جراحه التجميل من هو
اوسم رجل في العالم
والله ما اقدر اقول لك مين يعني اذا كان
في شخص معين تنطبق عليه همم
مواصفات فعندكم
المشابهه للممثل المذكور عندكم ياسر
القحطاني يعني ما شاء الله
شكرا لك